on rentre tous à l'intérieur vous prenez
de trois chariots première étape
l'enseigné intermarché à saint marcel
une quarantaine d'éleveurs ont épluché
les étiquettes de provenance des viandes
viande limousine et ports français avec
les responsables du magasin eux aussi
sensibilisés aux arguments de ces
derniers franchement les éleveurs c'est
plus des partenaires pour nous qu'autre
chose puisque vous avez entendu on vend
que des bêtes limousine élevé dans
l'indre enfin je parle des carcasses ça
nous désole de voir qu'il ya des gens
qui sont ici parce que d'un quelque part
et ils ont des problèmes on peut pas
faire grand chose sur un magasin tout
seul peut peut-être faire quelque chose
sur l'enseigné je me suis engagé à faire
remonter les revendications de ces
messieurs on a voulu venir dans notre
ville parce que s'il ya des choses bien
à faire remarquer bas on veut les faire
remarquer puis s'il ya des choses moins
bien on veut les faire voir aussi si le
deuxième magasin visité affichait aussi
la provenance française de la viande
les investigations des et murray les
soulever un lièvre de taille ou son sens
du poseur un jour c'est pas possible
d'en arriver là et de voir que
de produire on m'a des cahiers des
charges à respecter face à cette
présence d'asticots mort dans la palette
de lait les agriculteurs décidé de
rester jusqu'au constat par
l'administration de ce problème
le contrôleur dépêchés sur place a donc
consignés dans l'urgence et les faits
reprochés aux magasins les risques
encourus pour ce type d'infraction ça va
être des constats qui vont être relevés
qui vont être notifiée à ces messieurs
dames et avec apport de justificatifs
pour savoir qu'effectivement ces
produits ont bien été retirés de la
consommation pour ce magasin il faudra
donc s'attendre à d'autres contrôles
dans les prochains jours quant aux
agriculteurs qui avaient bloqué quelque
temps le centre ville il annonce d'ores
et déjà d'autres opérations